non-minimalists
life pockets i'd love to know how you
deal with guilt
when you do slip up i've stopped
unnecessary material purchases but
sometimes i cave
and make spontaneous purchases which
then led to guilt
how do you react to this you know what's
funny about this is i chew my nails
that's how i react to all my guilt
well the framing of the question is
fascinating right because
she says here that i've stopped
unnecessary
material purchases but sometimes i make
unnecessary material purchases
and like there's a weird sort of denial
here right and
what what role does denial play in guilt
yeah can i tell you a story from ireland
that i think fits with us
this guy goes to this bar every week
this guy's sheamus right
and he always orders four pints of beer
all right so always works for
and drinks four pints of guinness bam
does this are every week
one week he comes in and he orders three
pints of guinness
and uh the bar man's pouring again and
says seamus he says you always
buy about four pints again it's never
asked why noise suddenly it's three
pints again it's what's going on
and sheamus says oh he says he says to
be honest with you he says i have
i have two brothers and a father and
they're all in different parts of the
world
and so every week little ritual i order
a pint for all of us i drink
in honor of all of us right that's
beautiful but he said very sad to say my
father passed away so
i'm just having a drink now for me and
for my two brothers
that's a beautiful rachel sorry for your
loss right so
six months goes by and then sheamus
comes in and he orders two pints of
guinness
and the bar man feels a bit guilty and
says like i don't want to pry but
has something happened to one of your
brothers and sheamus says no no no he
says no no he says doctor's orders i've
had to stop drinking
right
so that i think that's yeah that's a
structure that we're all in in a way we
can
sometimes like be talking about
environmental issues while making an
unnecessary journey or whatever
is that we bizarrely do the very
activity
that we're disavowing so yeah that's
very yeah
so if i'm talking to to life pockets
here uh
the thing is what you're saying is i'm
imperfect
yeah and i acknowledge yeah you are
imperfect
yeah wait a minute
no and so of course you you might slip
up
uh or you might just realize the the
purchase you
you made to be more charitable here you
thought might be necessary or
or value adding in a way was not it did
not accomplish the thing
that you wanted now you can of course
set some boundaries up beforehand
to help you make better decisions going
forward right you know there are simple
rules you can set like what we call the
30 30 rule it's basically like if
something costs more than 30 bucks
wait 30 hours it at least gives you some
time to reflect and you realize in that
time like oh the thing i thought i
needed i don't actually need and
probably won't get much value from
and so i'm going to abstain from that
they're also we have this thing six
questions
asked before buying but one of those
questions is is this the best use of
this money
because money is a resource that um
is not unlimited at least not for most
of us and so
if i have 100 bucks and i can afford to
buy this hundred dollar thing
is that the best use of this hundred
dollars or would i get more value from
spending that hundred dollars
in a different way and so there's some
questions i think you can ask
before you make the purchase but if you
are in that position now where you have
made the purchase
it's a sunk cost and you're going to
have to move on because
you or you can continue to carry that
guilt with you in perpetuity but i don't
think it's going to serve you much if
you
continue to cling to it that's true and
you could in light of the conversation
we've had
is also go oh that guilt that i'm
feeling
that's a sign of my freedom because like
in terms of this whole conversation it's
like saying that
what what that person what was the
person's name sorry life pockets
life pockets rather nice
lp's experiencing is this
this being between who they are and who
they would like to be
right um and we all live between who we
are who we'd like to be
what we have what we'd like to have and
that experience of guilt
is that experience of one's freedom and
if you can just
shift your experience of that you can go
yeah you might want to change or
whatever but
that shows that you're human you know so
i go like yeah
so you snap at me um and say i
i then you feel guilty so you feel
guilty because you snapped at me
if i you know we're in a relationship
and i say to you
it's okay like i know you're stressed
that's a forgiveness of debt
i so the lack and the guilt that you're
feeling the debt that you're feeling is
now
dissipated and then that actually leads
to an improvement in one's behavior so
that's the kind of logic that i'm
talking about and this is displacement
as well so displacement is
is where you take anger that's that's
generated in one place and you put it
somewhere else
so a really obvious example is if you
have a child
and you're having to get up and look
after the kid all the time you can get
annoyed at your kid yeah okay
but you can't be annoyed your kid
because your kid's a baby so you shout
at your partner
right everyone knows that happens yeah
and and so your partner
goes like oh you're displacing or you
had a tough day at work you can't
shout at your boss or you'll get fired
so you come home when you shout at your
partner right
and your partner if it's a healthy
relationship will go oh yeah
that's displacement they had a difficult
day at work they accept it
that there's a lot of maturity to get
there though well yeah but if
if you have that and then they forgive
you as in they go
that's okay listen i know you you've had
to get up three times tonight and and
feed the kid
so the fact you shouted at me i
completely understand don't even give it
a seconds thought
you experience the forgiveness you the
the guilt diminishes and
and and you will probably you know
improve the behavior over time yeah
yeah absolutely and you know i think the
best way to uh get your partner to that
maturity level
is you start to do it yourself because i
know with um
like mariah and i will i don't know it's
like the silliest things uh
like we'll start talking about i don't
know like masks
for example and i'll say like i could
see why people are at this place where
they're upset with masks
and then mariah will say we this isn't
an actual argument i'm just trying to
think of an example and then she'll say
something like
yeah yeah but people shouldn't be at
that place and uh people should just
pull their masks i'm like yeah i know
but i'm just trying to say that here's
why they go and we start to
like butt heads on a silly subject like
i'll stop and i'll be like all right
like this is like getting we're getting
angry for no reason
about this subject that has nothing to
do with our immediate lives yeah well
that's what he was talking about earlier
with the
uh the creationism where someone that
you respected came along and said
hey this doesn't matter and sometimes i
think we can do that in our own
relationships yeah and like
yeah and so when you step up to be that
mature person it makes your
partner want to be that mature mature
person also oh absolutely that's why
we used to do a thing called the
evangelism project where we went
i took a group of people to be
evangelized by a different say religion
and the idea was not so much that you
were evangelized by the other religion
but partly that you saw yourself through
their eyes you would see
yourself better and you'd be evangelized
you'd be drawn to be better but
what happened in that interaction is in
being
open to letting the other speak into
your life
they become more open to you also you
speaking into their life
and the the whole thing breaks open so i
imagine say you're a republican you're
democrat
and traditionally if you're republican
you're trying to
convince him to be republican if you're
a democrat you're trying to convince him
to be democrat sure
but in this different environment
imagine you came in and you said
i'm not going to try and make you
republican i think you can make me a
better republican there's something i'm
missing because
i don't know why you're not a republican
like you're just this hippie dippy
whatever
i think right but actually but then
maybe there's something i'm missing
so tell me what i'm missing and vice
versa you say well i can't imagine why
you'd be a republican i can't like
that's a terrible thing
but am i missing something maybe you can
make me a better democrat
and weirdly now instead of trying to
make each other the opposite
the other person becomes an instrument
of your further transformation
an instrument of your further conversion
and then both
sides kind of move forward and there's
one last thing on that
i do think that the majority of times i
see people
falling for each other and and really
being drawn to each other one factor i
see is very important
is that often they feel that they can
say anything to the other
that the other can bear the weight of
them
and forgive them so forgiveness is such
a powerful thing that
sometimes to meet someone who says yeah
i can i can take your luck
i can cope with it and i can forgive
your lack because i know
that that's where this desire happens
and transformation happens
you